in 1997 Princess Diana shocked the world
by walking through a minefield in Angola
a short walk that drew more attention to
landmines than any other public campaign
22 years later
Prince Harry was marking another
important step forward as the government
in Angola has pledged 47 million pounds
to clear the mines I had the privilege
in 2013 a visiting angola with the halo
Trust in cuando Kabongo in the far
southeast of what is a vast beautiful
country I saw a struggling community in
a deserted landscape unable to make use
of the land yet the potential to turn
this land into a sustainable source for
its people in fact I was told just the
other day of the positive transformation
in Colombo since my mother walked that
minefield all those years ago what is
less well known is the impact land mines
can have on conservation and wildlife
and therefore visits to Mozambique in
2010 and then Angola three years later
had a huge impact on hairy
in Angola they are slowly clearing the
thousands of mines left from the Civil
War but the knock-on impact has been
huge the fear has stopped farmers from
using their land and the precious
wildlife is being targeted by poachers
because of rising levels of poverty the
area still has land mines fields
scattered throughout its territory which
in spite of government effort in
partnership with the mining companies
still deny human access to part of the
vast resources they put to lives of
wildlife flora and the entire coast
systems at risk
Angola may be benefitting from this
latest investment but the halo trust
hope the Dukes involvement will wake up
the wider international community the
numbers of people being hurt every year
rising at a horrible rate so we've got
to get at this we've got to do something
about it it's a humanitarian crisis that
we've got to get to grips with and so
his influence means that we can get
countries once again to commit us the
British have 100 million pounds it's a
start but I'd like to see more
it is anticipated that Harry and Megan
may visit Angola later this year as part
of a royal tour continuing his mother's
groundbreaking work Rhiannon Mills Sky
News